douze ans après tchernobyl les retombées
nucléaires sont fortes dans toutes les
alpes bernard kouchner est venu sur
place aujourd'hui rassurer la population
et rendre compte de la situation
olivier terran et diane richard la
chasse aux tâches radioactive s'est
déroulée sous les yeux de bernard
kouchner
les alpages du parc du mercantour sont
criblés de poing radioactifs contaminés
au césium 137
je confirme la valeur alors 700 sur
certains points la radioactivité est
largement supérieur aux normes
couramment admissible mais pour les
ingénieurs de l'eau prix l'office de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants un organisme d'état
le risque sanitaire reste minime
resterai ici toute l'année du début
jusqu'à la fin de l'année il un
cumulerait au bout de l'année la dose
maximale admissible pour la population
la dose la limite actuelle
la criirad l'organisme indépendant de
recherche sur la radioactivité qui a
alerté les pouvoirs publics et l'opinion
il ya quelques mois n'est pas aussi
optimiste
il demande un engagement de l'état ce
que nous disons tout d'abord c'est que
la contamination de ces massifs est
importante 10 100 fois la radioactivité
naturelle que la situation n'est pas
banale et que donc il faut prendre des
mesures pour protéger la population et
limiter ses doses la situation n'est pas
catastrophique mais un discours qui
consisterait à dire que tout ça est
négligeable est inacceptable aujourd'hui
dans la vallée depuis quelques mois
c'est l'inquiétude alors à saint-etienne
de tinée bernard kouchner est allé à la
rencontre des gens pour leur expliquer
d'abord qu'il n'y avait pas de problème
pour leur santé et que des mesures de
prévention serait prise en fonction
je voudrais être clair ici dans le parc
du mercantour il n'y a aucun danger mais
il y a des zones de radioactivité plus
forte bien sûr trop forte qui sont peut
être balisé et qui sont le résultat très
circonscrit le long des pentes du nuage
de tchernobyl en 1986 alors il faut le
savoir le dire aux gens il ya des
précautions peut être dans certains
secteurs à propos des champignons faut
le dire peut-être dans les massifs on ne
fait pas de catastrophisme mais les
montagnes resteront acheter de
radioactivité supérieures aux normes
encore longtemps